can we talk about HBO or sorry Max oh
yes thank you thank you for clearing
that up contractually I can't talk about
uh yeah
um I mean I I am a rabid fan of the
righteous gemstones are you aware that
that my my lady and I dressed up as
uh
Uncle Billy oh Uncle baby Billy yeah
baby baby Billy yeah when's the last
time you dressed up for Halloween before
that yeah 20 years no I do it every year
now because of Lex yeah but uh but we
killed it that's sick like uh we we
killed it yeah and then what is it Aunt
Julie and Jill like uh baby Billy's girl
oh uh
it's so damn good and well her real name
is Valen uh she's she's a fantastic yeah
yeah
uh and uh yeah the show's so damn fun I
mean big pride has always been like a
comedy King to me so when he came and
was like yo you want to do this show
with me it was like we had just gotten
done doing Workaholics and it's been
like maybe a year or so afterwards and I
kind of was like I don't want to do TV
for a while I just want to like make do
my own thing do stand up figure out some
movies to do and then when Danny called
I was like yeah of course I'm not sure I
gotta do it and this is season three
coming on yep season three like the
pandemic kind of boned us a little bit
because
um you know no one could shoot anything
and we're about to go shoot season two
when it shut down and then so now we're
only on season three when in fact we
should be on like four or even uh I
think you're getting ready to go shoot
season two when we spoke last yeah
season two came out my my girl and I I
mean dude HBO half hour comedies man
like Silicon Valley was that just so
good Curb Your Enthusiasm right right
just gemstones yeah they do a good job
of like just letting their they hire
good people and then letting them do
what they want to do and yeah not
interfering and I think that's like
that's what Comedy Central used to be
really good at uh and I you know because
they really let us do what we wanted to
do uh but I think we we gotta ingest
under the wire where before you know
yeah uh Comedy Central is not even a
is that still a network I mean I think
it is like yeah it's like nothing's on
it anymore nothing that you anymore yeah
that you even know which sucks because
I'm sure there's some funny stuff it's
crazy yeah um the end of season two
felt like it was over
yeah Danny he he really wants to he's
like I don't I don't want to be in this
situation where you like
where you know we hope we think we're
coming back people love the show but
he's like I want every season to feel
like a self-contained thing right so
like if that's it you the audience is
like that was great I love that and not
feel like you're left going like well
they didn't finish telling the stories
you know yeah then you got to wait like
nine months for the next one to come out
yeah yeah or or even if you're you're
canceled and you don't come back and
then they're just like going like well
that sucks what happened right it's bad
luck that Danny's Danny's just the king
he's really oh yeah have you met him I
don't think I've ever met him yeah he's
he's the he's the he's like just as
cool as you want him to be you know and
he lives in North Carolina South
Carolina Charleston just doesn't really
get in the mix too much yeah he lived
here for like 20 years and then like I
think they shot uh Vice principals which
is a show right before gemstones and
they
um they shot in Charleston and he had
like I don't think he'd spend that much
time in Charleston and then shooting
there uh for like they shot for like a
year because they shot two seasons back
to back and he was like I fell in love
with it he said he came back got his
stuff and uh and like 20 families moved
out with him and he just like moved out
with the whole a whole crew of people
and he was like let's just let's start
Hollywood South yeah yeah I love that
man so
um now that is righteous Jim Jones
already airing it is yeah the first two
episodes just came on last Sunday and
then now it'll be uh every Sunday for
the next you know what seven more weeks
or something dude fantastic my girl and
I are not allowed to watch it alone yeah
that's like an appointment watching for
us together well that's that's good and
don't do it because that's how
relationships implode over things like
that yeah yeah big time yeah you could
you could lose it all right
do you like shopping on Amazon time I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butt hole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah I do